one of the things I've been talking
about during the last year of Donald
Trump's presidency and during the
campaign and during the transition
period enduring Joe Biden's nascent
presidency is that the Republican party
at this point has stopped even
pretending to be about policy and values
and is merely about performative outrage
misplaced outrage laughable outrage
we're going to look at an example in a
moment but I think this is an important
sort of reset to do and I know many of
you might be thinking David you know the
Republican Party hasn't really been
about policy for a very long time that's
true but they used to pretend to be
about policy for a Time the Republican
Party really was about tax cuts for the
rich cutting budgets by cutting Social
programs uh spreading spreading the
quote spreading democracy through
invasive foreign policy around the world
they tried passing bills to get these
things done eventually during the end of
the Bush era and into the Barack Obama
presidency both terms the Republican
party started to become about policy in
name only but not sincerely
they went from really trying to do
policy to just talking about it but not
really caring about policy you know
they'd claim to be about cutting the
deficit and reducing the debt and fiscal
responsibility but not when George W
bush wanted to explode the deficit by
going to war with the wrong country and
they refused to acknowledge when Barack
Obama did cut the deficit so they went
from being about a few policies bad
policies policies I disagreed with two
only claiming to be about those policies
while not actually doing a thing about
it and we saw more and more that the
Republican Party became obsessed with
grievances the so-called War on
Christmas they were fighting fighting
non-existent censorship fighting
non-existent depression by gay people at
what they called the gay Lobby rather
than of lgbtq folks that type of thing
and then Trump ran on policy terrible
policy but he ran on it and then just
didn't do it when he became president of
the United States he ran on building a
the wall he didn't build it he ran on
replacing Obamacare with a beautiful new
health care plan plan never existed I
think we're still two weeks away from
Trump unveiling it even though he's out
of office he ran on paying off the debt
in one term he did the opposite and over
the presidency of Donald Trump the
Republican party went from being about
these bad policy ideas to being about
the news is fake
you can only trust us everybody else is
lying to you Democrats are censoring you
and a social media is censoring you and
us they're being unfair to Trump they're
canceling Thanksgiving they're canceling
Christmas they're canceling the
Constitution they're canceling you know
covet guidelines violate the
constitution and so what we have left
today is a trumpian Republican party
that is about nothing other than
performative outrage what policy is
Marjorie Taylor green about nothing she
barely even pretends to be about policy
because she knows nothing about policy
and it's essentially a grievance
campaign what policy is Madison
cawthorne about nothing and in fact
we've gotten reports from inside his
staff that he is running a
communications platform rather than a
policy platform we know we could tell
it's all about being outraged at the
left for things that don't even exist
and right-wing media has jumped on the
train probably because it's profitable
for them I'm going to play a clip now
that is the epitome of this Fox News
invited a Minnesota Republican state
senator named Julia Coleman on why did
they do that because she's Furious and
Fox News is outraged that Minnesota
educational standards don't rail against
socialism enough
and that's the reason that she's
outraged take a look standards have a
stated purpose more like that of the
1619 project than that of maintaining
Freedom well that it's all part of an
evolution that went from the Civics
Department to social studies uh here's a
here's what we had we actually reached
out to the Minnesota Department of
Education for a statement here's a
portion of what they said they said the
benchmarks listed in this first draft
are simply examples of what could be
included under each standard historical
U.S events like World War II and the
Holocaust are being taught in Minnesota
schools we welcome Senator Coleman's
feedback as we as well as the feedback
of every American So based on what
you've revealed do you feel like they're
fairly including uh portions of say
World War II and would they exclude them
if no one spoke up about it if you
didn't expose this what would they get
away with
well quite frankly Pete this is not
exactly true what they're saying because
5 000 parents in Minnesota reached out
to the review board stating their
concerns and they were brushed off in a
recent meeting now if you're having
trouble understanding what she's so mad
about and what fox host Pete hegseth is
so mad about it's because it's all a
performative farce this is what the
Republican Party in the immediate
post-trump era is about nothing outrage
porn based on nothing now the question
becomes
and it's a it's an important question
for the Republican party to answer how
long can the Republican Party survive on
the platform of baseless outrage for a
while it will work because you're
getting people outraged but if they
continue to be about imaginary
censorship while voting against the
coveted relief bill that Joe Biden and
Democrats get done and it gets money to
people and voters know it what is this
outrage performative nonsense do for
them in the 2022 midterms I don't know
the answer and it remains to be seen but
it could be very very bad and we'll talk
about it a little bit more later in the
context of this third party that Donald
Trump is looking at and which 64 percent
of Republicans if you can believe it
would be open to joining and abandoning
the Republican Party we'll talk about
that later you can find me on Twitter at
dpacman